Chelsea welcome to the set of Empire I
have a cameo today that's why I'm
carrying around my sides like I'm an
actor and look who's with me just a
smaller one and only he's working with
me today on my scene how am i doing so
far
okay so this is my trailer right here
and as you can see they put your name on
the it's supposed to come phrase your
night inner interview
interviewer I'm trying to get my
rehearsal in you see you see I okay as a
professional actor and Jamal Jamal I
don't believe it
Jamal gets on the set of Empire this mic
really doesn't work what I'm about to do
my scene seemed really really happy
what's up what's up my episodes that's
right I said my episode is scheduled to
air sometime in November meanwhile
empires back tonight so make sure you
tune in Nichelle Keltie back to you I
have to go act like a fool acting like
listen we know his scenes are gonna get
cut oh wow you're getting some credit
and say we should have a watch party but
no I'm with that yeah
[Music]